if you are a young business graduate and
are thinking about what the first job
should be that you should accept fresh
out of university and if you are looking
to be successful in the business world
in the long term I believe in my humble
opinion the joining consulting firm is
probably the best career move that you
can take but before we jump into that I
have some great news to share
look at this baby that arrived over the
weekend let's take a few moments to
celebrate this baby hi guys how is it
going hope you're all having a great day
so this is not the first time I'm
filming with my new equipment so I got
myself a new camera a new microphone and
a new lens over the weekend so hope you
see some kind of difference the Easter
holidays for me are a great way to
reconnect with myself with my family and
my friends hope you also had a similar
great experience at home I know the
current times are difficult it is going
to be a very special Easter holiday for
most of us in the last days I tried to
work on a few things I set up my
Instagram channel for you again I'm
currently posting several pieces of
content there every single day so let me
know if you have any feedback for me I
would HIGHLY appreciate your views but
now back to the studio and welcome once
again to another coffee break with firm
learning for those of you who are
regular Watchers and subscribers of this
channel thank you so much for your time
and for those of you watch the first
time first of all welcome my name is
Heinrich and here on firm learning I
want to help you become successful in
the first years of your career
this video is all about consulting it
covers what I believe it is extremely
valuable ahead for it to start off your
business career as a consultant even
though if you actually want to do
something else in the long term and
becoming a consultant is not something
that you plan to do forever so if you
take any value out of this video at all
please press the like button for the
YouTube algorithm and also subscribe and
hit the notification there to stay up to
date and receive all the regular content
and I'm putting out there for you at the
moment I'm releasing at least one video
every single Saturday and in many weeks
there's going even to be a second video
for you guys so if you are graduate
from University soon you will likely ask
yourself the question what should be the
first job what should be the first role
that I should take when I now start my
career what does a wise career move the
first thing that I should start the
first job that I should take and when I
graduated from my master program at the
London School of Economics I asked
myself the same question and in my mind
a bit in a stylized way I saw four
options that you can take as a business
graduate you can either go into
consulting you can go into banking you
can work in industry or you can start a
startup of course this is grossly
simplified but if you break it down this
is pretty much what you can do these are
your options so let's briefly go over
the startup and the banking choice I
believe that these two choices are
really specific choices to people whose
passion it is to do exactly these things
so if you want to do a startup if you
want to become an entrepreneur you're
probably not thinking about whether you
should take on an industry job most
entrepreneurs I know they just have it
in your blood if you want to start a
business if you want to become an
entrepreneur do a startup there's no
other options for you and in this video
I'm not going to try to convince you to
do something else
I believe doing a startup is amazing if
this is how you're ticking if this is
what your passion is then go for it
I fully have your back go on in this is
great and even though on the one side
it's completely different on the other
side kind of similar to that is banking
from my experience there is a special
type of business students a special type
of people and personalities want to go
down the banking path and even though
banking now is probably a bit less
relevant to many people than it was
roughly 10 years ago when I graduated
for my master program banking still can
be a great career option for you I have
many friends who work in investment
banks or private equity or similar role
and they're very much enjoy it and of
course it can be a highly attractive
form of financial side this way so
startup and banking for this video I
went a bit put aside because I believe
why these are very viable options either
you want to do it or you don't
so the more interesting question where I
see people struggle with is for the
other two sectors it's for consulting or
for industry so if you are a young
graduate usually should you
pick the consulting on the industry path
and just to be clear here on terminology
with industry I mean the more regular
standard business companies across all
industries so let it be automotive let
it be advanced industries that be retail
farmer Island gas telecommunication all
of this is what I summarized under the
industry labor so how does a typical
industry started job compared to a
typical consulting starter job and I
know now that in the comments people
were right there of course there's a
huge diversity of jobs both an industry
and consulting and yes you're completely
right but I just try to generalize here
but because I do believe that many of
the roads within industry and then
within the consulting are pretty similar
incomparable so in a typical industry
role you start in one department so you
will either based and business
development or maybe managerial
accounting or production or sales and
then you work in that team for timespan
of several years you will be indicated
to a fixed team you will have your one
supervisor and then the game for you is
pretty much growing into this role
really becoming a part of the team and
then becoming a part of the day-to-day
operations of the business and trying to
really move the business forward making
an impact in the business in every day
that you work there so how does this
compare to consulting well and if I talk
about consulting I of course especially
mean the last strategy consulting firms
like BCG Bane or McKinsey where you are
usually in a setting where you work in a
very small team of two three or four
people on the ground for one client
typical project will go on for a
duration of two to five months and then
project four project you will usually
change functions change industries
change clients and then over course of
several years get exposure to many of
these different situations by then over
time after you are two three four years
down into your consulting role you will
then specialize more and more generally
on one industry to then really become an
expert in one of these fields so why no
doubt there are disadvantages as well
when working in consulting in this video
I will argue that I believe for most
people out there who are a young
business graduate and are looking to
make a mark in the business world in the
long
for most of these people it is the best
choice to start a strategy consulting
firm such as McKinsey Bane or BCG if
you're looking for the first job that
you can take in your career so let me
tell you five strong reasons why I
believe that this is the case so the
first reason that I see is the size of a
team if you work at McKinsey or BCG
typical team size is two to four people
on a typical project there will be one
project leader on the ground and then
two associates supporting him at the
client if you start as a consultant you
will from the first week on be staffed
on a client project and will become one
of these three members of your project
team then usually what happens is that
the project lead will divide the project
into different work streams so pretty
much packages of work that need to be
done and then distribute them to all the
team members so each of the associates
and the project lead them safe we have a
certain set of tasks that he is
responsible for so imagine there's a
company with two business units and as a
BCG consultant now you are being asked
to identify cost improvement potentials
for these two business units so in such
a project what will typically happen is
that there are two associates each
associate is responsible for one of the
business units and then there's the
project leader will take care of some
maybe minor tasks left and right and of
course is responsible for the overall
quality of the output of the team what
you quickly realize that actually I'm
concerned is that from early on you will
be alone sitting in meetings with senior
clients of this business units will
pretty much work on yourself pushing
forward the topics that you need to do
and if you for whatever reason fail to
do that if you're not able to do that
the whole team will struggle a lot
because obviously the other associate
cannot also take care of your whole
business unit because he is already
highly utilized but the work that he is
doing the project it of course has many
things to do and yes for sure he will
help you and cover you but he cannot
pick up all the slack of your work if
you are not doing it so what this means
is that from early on you will be a
critical fundamental part of the team
and the whole team
automatically rely on you getting the
job done and doing good work and trust
me that this is vastly different from
working an industry where usually you
are part of a big team you have 10 20 30
40 other people working in your
department and then as a new joiner
maybe they transfer a few minor tasks to
you that you then can work on but the
most of these roles it's not a real
serious problem if you for whatever
reasons it's rather because there will
be other people who can help you out if
it's really not working out they can
likely also completely cover all your
tasks especially in the beginning to
give you some time to really grow into
your role in the first year or so in
consulting it's different you would be
expected to grow into your role within
weeks this very much feels like being
thrown into the cold water and it can
sometimes be quite a frightening
experience for a new business joiner
but this is exactly why the learning
curve in consulting is so high why you
will learn such a tremendous amount of
things after working for consulting
within only one or two years it is a
learning experience that is pretty much
unparalleled and almost all industry
jobs out there reason number two is the
exposure that you get to many different
leadership styles and this is something
that I believe many people significantly
undervalue when they are thinking about
joining a job in industry cause an
industry you're part of a fixed team and
this means that your supervisor or your
team lead will usually be constant will
be fixed for a long period of time so if
you're there for three years four years
five years maybe even longer it could be
the case that all the time you work with
and for the very same team lead or Team
Manager the whole time and why this of
course has some advantages and there can
be a deep mentoring relationship coming
out of that the big downside is that you
get exposure so only this one leadership
style and this could not be more
different than what you will experience
when you work in consulting in
consulting every two to five months you
will work on a new project and this
usually involves the dual work with a
new project lead mine of course it is
true that there is a certain homogeneous
culture in a consulting firm like BCG or
McKinsey the truth is also that still
the leadership styles of the people are
sometimes vastly different the way your
project
it will handle difficult client meetings
the way your project lead will react
with a more senior partner of the
consulting firm pushes the project team
in a certain direction but if he
believes that this is not the right
direction how he were pushed back to the
senior leadership would be vastly
different among the different people how
he handles a team how he motivates you
how he interacts with you all of this
will be vastly different from person to
person and as a consultant sitting on
the receiving end of this internal
leadership that you get this gives you
the opportunity to self-reflect a lot
because this is as if there would be
lots of experiments happening just in
front of you you can watch all these
project leads of you trying out
different things different styles and
seeing what is working what is not
working and of course you will
frequently see these people do certain
things and the end you will tell
yourself by probably I would have handed
this situation in a different way
probably the way that he handed this
didn't really work out that way you
should probably have done something else
and the fact that you see all these
different styles in the short amount of
time really enables you to ask yourself
what is the type of leader that you want
to become what does the leadership style
that you want to adopt in the exposure
to all these different styles from my
experience is extremely valuable and
this is something that you will just not
get at oil if you work in industry or in
another position where your boss your
supervisor will be the very same person
for a long amount of time and this now
leads me to reason number three and this
is that an industry often highly
dependent on a small amount of people
and especially your direct supervisor
how your work is evaluated whether you
are considered as a strong performer or
not what your internal performance
rating will be in industry were very
much depend on your direct supervisor
and of course this can be a big plus if
you happen to get along really well with
the person but on the other hand side if
you do not get along with the person
really well
this can become a huge problem for you
because pretty much the only choice that
you have is either transition roles
within the company which is often easier
said than done or change your job to a
completely new employer which of course
is not something that you often want to
do if you're just within the first year
or so of your career so if you compare
that now to concise
in consulting you usually change the
teams every couple of months and this
means that if you happen to work with
the Project Lead for whom you and
probably then also the project lead
realizes that this isn't really a good
fit in a few months you will change the
team it's in new game there will be a
new person who can work with then over
time you will have build a network of
project needs of partners with whom you
enjoy working and then hopefully also on
the other side they will enjoy working
with you and then you can actively try
to seek out working together with these
people more and more they then
appreciate you as where they of course
will be more than happy to work with you
again and again and by this you can
really build your own community you can
build your own firm within the
consulting firm and in consulting this
is then how mutually beneficial
mentorship relationships can be built
because you want to work again with
these project leads the partners want to
work again with you because they know
that you are a rockstar you are loyal
you will do great work for them on their
projects this is really completely
different to how it works in the
industry reason number four is the sheer
amount experiences that you get when
working for large strategy consulting
firm like McKinsey or BCG when you start
out with your career you remise six
years at McKinsey I have been involved
in lots of projects covering all types
of industries and functions I have been
involved in large M&A mergers and
acquisitions transactions I've been
working on major cost and revenue
transformations of large groups of
companies I've worked on all kinds of
countries within an outside of Europe I
work together with buying departments
helping them improve their direct and
indirect spend I developed new sales
strategies for large chemicals companies
new pricing structures for retail
companies evaluated the capex pipeline
for automotive suppliers and many many
many more things I would argue that is
just impossible to get that amount of
experience in that little time if we
work in pretty much any regular industry
role and last but not least be exposure
to sea level management of large budget
companies that you get early on on many
projects we work closely together with
CEOs CFOs
of large companies we work together with
business unit heads with really senior
level management of the companies these
are people that if you work in a normal
department
and Industry royal might never even
speak to face-to-face in the first years
of your career and to the contrary as a
McKinsey o BCG consultant you sit
together in a room with them and work
together with them on the most pressing
top-of-mind issues that these c-level
executives have in their head and they
seek your expertise they respect you and
they closely work together with you to
solve these high priority issues of
their companies this is just
unparalleled this will not be possible
in most industry roads so looking at
these five reasons I honestly believe
that pretty much independent of what you
want to do in the long term you will
benefit from having worked a couple of
years in a large strategy consulting
firm such as McKinsey or BCG but also do
not get me wrong consulting is not
perfect it's not a fairy tale it's no
lala land that you work in and
everything is just great and amazing
there are some significant downsides of
working in consulting as well and here
I'm not even talking about work-life
balance but rather specific learnings
that I believe are crucial and
absolutely needed for you to be
successful in the long term but which
you will not develop at all in
consulting so this could actually be
another video me talking about what the
things are that you will for sure not
learn in consulting so if this is
something that would interest you please
let me know below in the comments and I
likely make another video on that in the
couple of weeks but just because there
are some things which you will not learn
in consulting I also believe that it is
important that after a couple of years
you are thinking about making a
transition and going into a more
operational more hands-on role your
development path of becoming a good
well-versed business professional of
becoming a good general manager would
just not be completed if you're just
working your consulting you need to
small operational line management
experience this way so what is your
thinking on all of this let me know your
opinion below in the comments probably
some of you thinking that I'm wrong and
consulting is not the best role to star
to see young business professionals so
very happy to have an open conversation
here let me know what your thoughts are
and I will give you an answer below in
the comments and again if you took any
value out of this video at all please
hit the like button for the YouTube
algorithm and also hit the
right button as well as activate the
notification there to stay informed and
up-to-date on all the future content I
have planned for you I will release at
least one video every single Saturday
and as some of you have already seen I'm
pretty active on my Instagram and
posting new content every single day
there so follow me on my Instagram
handle firm learning to stay posted
thank you for watching everybody stay
safe and keep learning this is highly
firm firm learning